[Music]
Xbox one owners won't be able to use the
multitasking feature snap after an
update this spring the feature was
removed in a recent update for Xbox
insiders and has now been addressed by
Microsoft I'm Matt and hey don't worry
you'll always be able to watch this
GameSpot news update as much as you want
Xbox engineering lead Mike Ibarra
addressed steps removal on Twitter
saying that Microsoft replaced snap to
improve multitasking reduce memory use
improve overall speed and free up
resources going forward for bigger
things this decision isn't a total
surprise as a report from November said
the company was looking to get rid of
the feature however Xbox one owners
looking to keep up on their achievements
will be able to use a snap style overlay
that will let them track their progress
the update is live now for some Xbox
insiders but it'll become available for
everyone sometime this spring
Microsoft says that the goal for this
update is to simplify its UI and improve
overall performance as it acknowledges
that the UI can be complex and for
certain tasks can require too many
button presses we'll keep you updated as
further information is revealed so for
that and more from the world of view
games stay tuned to game spot
you